*Silent Night plays*
Narrator: T'was the night before Christmas, and all through the  house...
Not a creature was stirring, not even a mouse...
*Creeeeek Step Step Step*
Stockings were hung by the chimney with care...
In hopes that St. Nicholas soon would be there...
(Turkey noises)
When up on the roof there arose such a clatter...
I sprang from my bed to see what was the matter...
Away to the windows I flew like a flash,
Tore open the shutters, and threw up the sash...
As I drew in my head and was turning around...
Down the chimney, St. Nicholas came with a bound...
A wink of his eye, and a twist of his head...
Soon gave me to know, I had everything to dread...
He spoke not a word, but went straight to his work...
And filled all the stockings, then turned with a jerk...
But I heard him exclaim, 'ere he drove out of sight
Santa (creepily): Ho, ho, ho...
Narrator: Merry Christmas to all...
And to all a good night...